así es gracias por permitirnos compartir
nuestra historia hoy se cumplen 57 días
desde que mi esposo fue desaparecido por
el régimen de daniel ortega y rosario
murillo ni su familia y nicaragua ni sus
abogados han podido acceder a él no han
podido hablar con él no le han visto no
sabemos si está dándole si les están
dando su medicamento no sabemos nada
acerca de su condición y así mismo se
encuentra el resto de los secuestrados
hasta la fecha en los últimos dos meses
el régimen ha detenido a 31 personas
entre ellas se encuentra en cinco casas
por cárcel y el resto está desaparecida
es decir incomunicado completamente
ahora abarca cuestiones que pueden hacer
desde la oposición planean presentarnos
en algún tipo de recurso alguna acción
para frenar o por lo menos para poder
dar ciertas condiciones a los comicios
de noviembre
en mi caso no puedo opinar alrededor de
las acciones de la oposición política yo
estoy aquí como esposa y como madre sin
embargo puedo decirte de que el proceso
electoral que actualmente nicaragua está
pasando para nosotras las dos para los
familiares de los presos políticos desde
ya es completamente ilegítimo irregular
arbitrario porque 7 o ahora ocho
precandidatos están en prisión hoy casa
por cárcel entonces desde entonces nos
preguntamos no qué tipo de proceso
electoral puede ser este cuando no
cumple ninguna condición bajo los
estándares internacionales como usted
decía bueno usted se encuentra en el
exilio y también la comunidad
internacional juega un rol en esta
problemática de la unión europea ha
impuesto sanciones a nicaragua varias
figuras no obstante las detenciones
continúan bueno usted como decíamos está
fuera del país que se puede hacer desde
allí desde la comunidad internacional
verdad
junto con victoria cárdenas esposa de
juan sebastián chamorro otro de los
candidatos que está desaparecido hemos
estado haciendo este advocacy como
llamamos ante la comunidad internacional
y nuestra solicitud es que realmente los
estados que tienen relación con
nicaragua logren ejercer y poner en
marcha cualquier tipo de mecanismo o
cualquier tipo de acción para
comunicarle al régimen de la enero
ortega que no pueda seguir violando los
derechos humanos de los nicaragüenses y
que accedan a tener realmente unas
elecciones libres y transparentes verdad
hace muchísimas gracias por su presencia
en france 24